madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
attention à la foudre dans le midi de la
france la météo prévoit en effet de
violents orages accompagnés de décharge
électrique pendant toute cette journée
de dimanche sur les régions
méditerranéennes
déjà hier la foudre est tombée à
clermont ferrand sur un terrain de rugby
le joueur international
jean-françois phliponeau a été foudroyé
foudroyé également un étudiant français
hier après midi à londres
il s'était réfugié sous un arbre pour se
protéger d'un orage vous le constatez la
foudre continuent à tuer en 1976 la
foudre que nous croyons bien connaître
et qui en fait est un phénomène
météorologique que nous commençons à
peine à comprendre
voici le résultat spectaculaire des plus
récentes recherches que vous explique
michel chevalet oui jean claude bourret
on croit connaître la foudre en fait ce
qu'il faut bien se dire c'est qu'à
chaque seconde à la surface de la terre
il y a en moyenne près d'une centaine d
clair je dis bien à chaque seconde
hélas les éclairs et bien on le sait ce
sont des décharges électriques dans
lesquelles est bien les courants se
mesurent en millions de volts et les
intensités au vote avoisine à peu près
dix mille ans père et le tout ne dure
que quelques millièmes de seconde alors
je propose d'avancer de regarder des
éclairs extrêmement spectaculaire
[Musique]
à la base toujours le cumulonimbus à la
base du nuage des décharges électriques
puis par de la base du nuage en
direction du sol ce qu'on appelle un
traceur c'est à dire un petit d'art qui
avancent par bond de 50 mètres ils
cherchent en quelque sorte de canal le
plus conducteur puis à 20 mètres du sol
par un deuxième traceur qui se dirige en
direction de lui une fois que la
jonction est faite et bien les charges
électriques s'engouffre dans le canal en
direction du nuage je dis bien en direct
le nuage c'est à dire que la foudre la
voici part du sol en direction du nuage
et non l'un verse et ce phénomène est
bien se reproduire quatre cinq six fois
de suite voici la fin d'un éclair et
vous allez le voir au ralenti voilà la
mort d'un éclair quelques petites
gouttelettes de plasma porté à très
haute température
mais les scientifiques savent marre des
planches et les éclairs sur commande
regardez
on lance en direction du nuage une
petite fusée avec relié au sol par un
fil métallique et ce fil métallique
c'est en quelque sorte de conducteurs
alors lorsque l'on parle des clercs et
bien on vous donne toujours énormément
de conseils
rares sont les bons conseils le premier
point est bien c'est que finalement où
vous êtes plus en sécurité c'est dans
votre maison et dans votre voiture
ensuite on vous dit bien ne vous
approchez pas des objets pointus voilà
l'explication les charges électriques
ont la propriété de s'accumuler sur les
pointes c'est à dire qu'ici on va avoir
des charges électriques extrêmement
dense extrêmement important et de fait
les claira
c'est ici que l'éclair a le plus de
chances de monter vers le nuage
reste le cas de l'arbre alors là si vous
allez voir c'est très particulier
donc premier point un arbre un objet
pointu
ici beaucoup de charges électriques
l'éclair va donc partir de la base du
nuage c'est de la base de l'arbre c'est
certain mais deuxièmement si vous êtes
soûlard vous risquez donc de recevoir
une branche sur la tête mais ensuite et
c'est là c'est beaucoup plus subtil
si vous êtes ici c'est à dire à la base
de la remettons à une dizaine de mètres
et bien vous allez risquer d'être
foudroyée pourquoi parce que les charges
électriques qui sont dans le sol vont
être aspiré pompé au moment de la foudre
en direction du nuage et de fait
brutalement le corps humain qui était
portée à 1 million de volts va passer
d'un million de volts à 0 volts et là
vous serez foudroyé enfin dernier point
il ya ce qu'on appelle l'attention de
pas au voisinage d'un objet élevé au
moment de l'éclair il y à un million de
volts dans le sol mais tous les mètres
dans le sol
le potentiel diminue de 1000 volts
autrement dit entre les pattes avant et
les pattes arrière d'une vache
il y à 1500 volts et la vache sera
électrocuté simplement par la différence
de potentiel entre ses deux pieds voilà
jean claude bourret quelques aspects
pour le moins inattendu
[Musique]